the representations of male bodies in a
variety of media have become more
disproportionate relative to the average
male Luke Skywalker Han Solo from the
original Star Wars the action figurines
look like normal regular guys then for
the re-release they look jacked
magazines TV you see a similar pattern
being a young guy growing up and
thinking oh how am I supposed to look am
I attractive am I hot can you look for a
frame of reference let's say you see a
hundred male bodies in your media diet
per week the 100 that you see today in
2023 you come out on the negative end of
those comparisons much more than you did
20 30 years ago
what is muscle dysmorphia
you can think of it like reverse
anorexia sometimes it's been called big
rexia or muscle rexia if anorexia is a
preoccupation with wanting to be thin
and typically being successful at
achieving that then muscle is more fear
is the opposite direction the
preoccupation is wanting to be as
muscular as leanly muscular as possible
and it obviously extends Beyond just
being a hobby or a pleasurable Pastime
and it causes real misery and impairment
for the folks who have it what are the
risk factors for this
risk factors include things like
low self-esteem guys that have muscle
dysmorphia they almost always have
pretty low self-regard and training
dieting looking their best is one way to
feel better about themselves often it's
one of the few if not the only ways for
them to achieve that there is often a
history of bullying they may have been
skinny when they were younger maybe they
were fat and were teased and want to do
something about it they may have
experienced some trauma whether physical
sexual or similar often they're
perfectionists so they want to do a job
to their absolute best and they want it
done right which means that if they're
going to train they want the best
training regimen if they're going to
diet they want their diet to be on Lock
and they pour over research they really
can't stop
and often some obsessive compulsiveness
as well so folks that have muscle
dysmorphia will tell us you know when I
when I do something I really do it I go
for it it can get a little obsessive
about it what does that tell us about
why muscle dysmorphia comes about that
it's born out of
have is it feelings of weakness weakness
and and maybe some learned helplessness
perhaps in some regards and a few other
bit what does it tell us all of those
different risk factors you've just
explained there about why muscle
dysmorphia comes about
well
when your training is unlocked
and you die at some point it gives you a
sense of control it gives you a sense of
control and it gives you a sense of
achievement and having you know having a
feeling of control and
achieving and having success in any
Pursuit is generally and broadly great
but in muscle dysmorphia it becomes a
singular focus and generally speaking
when anything becomes a singular Focus
where it's the the serve to a wound like
low self-esteem it doesn't often work
out very favorably for the person
affected does it co-occur with anything
else so you mentioned there that people
tend to be slightly obsessive does that
mean that there is more obsessive
compulsive disorder is there autism
spectrum disorder is there anything else
yeah all of that slightly elevated I
think depression is what you see quite a
lot it's not clear that the depression
is there first I'd say it often comes
about afterward so if you have been
training and dieting that hard for so
long maybe it's cost you a relationship
or two maybe you don't I socialize with
your friends as much as you used to then
I mean depressions are fairly uh
understandable outcome of going through
that for some time
guys are muscle dysmorphia you know a
higher background rate of having anxiety
in general often some social anxiety
particularly when they were young so if
you're used to
thinking that others are are laughing
behind your back or judging you or that
you don't belong in social situations
those kinds of thought patterns are
going to set you up for that critical
self-analysis on how you appear to
others which is you know your muscles
your height any of the things that men
are often concerned about I suppose that
also creates a base of ruminative
thoughts to considering yourself how
other people see you if you're not
spending that much time in social
situations then the few social
situations that you do spend time in are
going to be judged
um a greater extent because there's
fewer incidents between you and other
people for you to think about which
means you'll ruminate about them more
which means that you'll think more about
your body image and how you can control
this and because you're not that
socially Adept you think well the way
that I should become more socially Adept
is by getting bigger in the gym because
that's the only thing that I've got
control over in my life and it means I
need to diet harder and if I get bigger
then the girls will like me yeah I mean
yeah exactly right you may be able to
tell a little bit of personal uh Story
coming through here but you know as
someone who
really didn't understand
um social dynamics very much especially
throughout school and then getting into
University
I really was just
like thrust into this hypersocial world
and I didn't understand how to navigate
it that much and this is you know
2006 2007 so like misc bodybuilding.com
forums and and yeah like I know exactly
what we're talking about like dude this
was before ziz so in the previous era
before If It Fits your Macros was
revolutionary and not old hat
um and that for me very quickly I
attached a lot of my sense of self-worth
to this you know I yeah throughout
second year and third year of uni
Thursday night Friday night Saturday
night I would be hosting in a nightclub
with my top off uh with a bunch of my
mates pouring drinks on everyone's
throats and having a good time like this
brand new Premiere the number one
nightclub in the city and that very
quickly attached my sense of self-worth
to the way that I looked because I was
the guy one of the few guys that was
walking about with his top off and I
meant if I was bigger if I was Alina
then people would respect me more and
yeah you can very quickly wrap your
sense of identity and self up in your
condition
yeah exactly and that often is true
especially when you're younger like
there's there's not that many Arenas
where young people can compete you know
in a social kind of way and Achieve
success and be respected people uh like
young people are not so different from
one another at that point you're all in
high school together the way you look is
such an easy thing to attach your
self-esteem and self-worth to and it's
so clearly digested by your peers as a
marker of social status and success so
it's no wonder that so many young people
end up getting into the kinds of mindset
that you found yourself in I found
myself attaching uh importance to my
appearance when I was a teen has almost
all teenagers do and now ultimately or
ideally as people get older you know
they they find a job that is their
passion they find interest how they find
their tribe suddenly there's lots of
different social Arenas that you can put
effort into and Achieve Prestige and and
feel good about yourself from there the
art your appearance but that takes time
that that's getting older what is the
age of onset for body dysmorphia amongst
males I'm gonna guess that
nine-year-olds don't have body
dysmorphia
no no they really do uh we know that
like young kids are aware that there are
ideal ways for men and women to look so
they pick up cues from society but in
terms of when muscle dysmorphia onsets
it's really after adolescence where you
start to see big differences due to
puberty in the rate at which boys are
developing suddenly you are short and
there are tall kids uh kids are getting
broader they're getting more muscles but
you've still got those skinny blanky
arms and a lot of adolescents are
suddenly aware that their body can be
different to their peers and then they
kind of thrust into this environment
where you throw uh sex and attraction
and dating on top of that where it feels
if you don't pay attention to this then
you're just not going to make it like
you're not going to have the respect to
get the girls uh so it's no wonder that
young men are susceptible to this kind
of thinking well it suggests that
there's maybe two things going on one
being that
almost all children are basically made
out of the same Rubber and magic and
broadly just like a blob with a face on
it but then you hit puberty at differing
rates and puberty kicks in and the
androgens set this guy off a little bit
more and this guy off a little bit less
yeah but the other thing being that
sexual selection and and being Chosen
and the desire to be chosen and
realizing that you yourself are a sexual
being is
very intimately linked with men's views
of and presumably females as well I'm
going to Guess That You Don't See
anorexia in like six six seven
eight-year-old girls either
no no typically not right what
how many men are there compared with
women who have body image issues that
would cross whatever the threshold is of
pathological
that's a great question I don't think
the data out there are convincing enough
yet for me to put a firm you know
prevalence estimate on that it's not as
common as for women so women by and
large experience more Eating Disorders
they're more likely to say they don't
like the way their body looks at all
levels of severity from just not really
liking it all the way up to the kinds of
severe body dissatisfaction that might
characterize Eating Disorders but it's
certainly there for men to get to give
you a sense of how the prevalence
estimates fall out around
one third to one quarter of the eating
disorders that are thinness oriented
about which we know quite a bit in
regards to prevalence they affect men
but of course the type of body that that
is thin and skinny is typically one that
that women will say they're after and
men will not when you look at muscle
dysmorphia the kind of more muscularity
oriented eating disorders that my team
have specialized in in recent years
those prevalent estimates switch
Suddenly It's like 80 90 of sufferers
are men which is what you might expect
we just don't have the big population
level data to slap a percentage of our
eating disorders and Body Image
disorders the same thing
but I think you can make a really good
case for that the the DSM which you use
in the states and we use here in
Australia to classify all manner of
psychological disorders it's it's not a
very old text like psychology psychiatry
in general compared to a physio
physiological medicine Physical Medicine
uh it's young so you have this category
of disorder called Eating Disorders you
have a category of disorder called body
dysmorphic disorder which is about body
image and you think uh these these two
seem to have a lot of similarities and
they're absolutely right you're
absolutely right and the way we would go
about treating it is pretty much exactly
the same it's just you know a quirk of a
diagnostic system that's constantly
evolving in response to evidence have
you worked out what the mechanism is
that's causing this to occur inside of
somebody's mind like so they see
themselves in the mirror they're able to
what they objectively see and what they
subjectively see begin to diverge more
and more that causes them to ruminate
about the image it causes them to use
self-referential thought it causes them
to be obsessive about their training to
eat more or to dial the calories in and
do all of these things
why like what what's going on inside of
these people's heads what are they what
are they hoping to achieve what like
what are the behaviors that these people
display what characterizes them
yeah
okay I I don't I don't have a an
excellent answer for you here because
the the number of
reasons the central reasons why muscle
dysmorphia can can come about are really
diverse we could have someone to take
the example you were providing who when
they look in the mirror there is some
perceptual Distortion that goes on in
their head so that what they see
reflected back at them is completely
Divergent from how they actually are and
how others see them this is the person
with muscle dysmorphia who is constantly
seeking reassurance they could be the
biggest guy in their friend group but
they're still terrified to take off
their shirt in case someone thinks that
you know they don't train like do you
even lift bro kind of mentality and they
exist but there are some guys who have
muscle dysmorphia they know exactly how
they look like they know
they know that they're the biggest guy
in their friend group one of the biggest
guys in the gym but it's just never
enough the goal posts are always moving
they get to one point get to one success
but then it's on to the next because
perceptual distortions are not the
motivating fact of it could have been as
in the words of one of the guys we were
interviewing with muscle dysmorphia
earlier this year that when he was
younger he got bullied for being scrawny
and uh this kid would come up and put
his fingers around this guy's wrist just
to show how skinny his wrist was and
from there came a whole bunch of very
critical uh commentary on his own body
and he's just never really been able to
outrun that he hasn't dealt with it
right so the underlying belief or
worldview is that
if I continue to train something will
happen that will fix the problem that
I've got inside
yeah it's that control right like if I
if I just if I get my training unlock if
my dieting is on Lock And if I keep just
doing this things will be better like
the underlying problem in security the
Distortion it will go away
but it's not going to it's for the same
reason that someone who has body
dysmorphic disorder they think their
nose is grotesquely misshapen even
though no one else can see it they go to
a cosmetic surgeon who says yeah I'll
fix your nose right up here's a nose job
they get it done and then they look in
the mirror and they go it still doesn't
look right
I think they've botched it I'm gonna
have to have another one because it's
not the problem it's just not the
underlying problem I saw an article that
I've had saved for the last couple of
months since I knew that you were coming
on which you may be familiar with poor
relationship with one's father
associated with heightened muscle
dysmorphia symptoms via vulnerable
narcissism you familiar with this
I'm familiar with the title I
so something that's been happening in
research on muscle dysmorphia that I
think is worth mentioning is folks who
do research uh and have been doing it
for some time in the area are wanting
more focus on studies with clinically
diagnosed individuals with muscle
dysmorphia the study in question you've
just mentioned no doubt has some value
but it's using self-report
questionnaires of muscle dysmorphia
symptoms and what tends to happen right
is you might get 300 college students
recruited into a study like that one and
you give them a symptom a symptom
questionnaire of muscle dysmorphia and
like the average level of muscle
dysmorphia symptoms when you look at it
is just up bunch of guys who go to the
gym and train it's not it's not the same
it's just not the same yeah uh and you
is you can say oh okay but if they score
above 20 we're going to say that you
know it's a it's our clinical cutoff and
they've probably got it
again it's just not the same we don't
know enough about muscle dysmorphia
you've really got to sit down with
someone for 45 minutes to work out if
them uh hitting the gym twice a day six
days a week is just something that they
do for fun because they're a bit of a
gym a gym rat or if it's an actual
problem so what's the what's the what's
the difference and I think this is
important because what we spoke about
earlier on this very high number of men
who are dissatisfied with their body in
one form or another but the difference
between it being you know a clinical
diagnosis or something that's
pathological end it being what almost
any guy who goes to the gym feels like
which is uh [__] I wish I you know I've
got this insertion thing on my bicep and
I really wish I could get that to be a
little bit more and oh you know it's the
lats because if I could get a little bit
more width on the lats I'd feel a little
bit more sort of Fuller from the back
that self-critical eye that everybody
has which can sometimes you know uh list
across into malicious
um and and even malignant but not
necessarily pathological or clinical
what's the line between them no I feel
you look if if we were diagnosing muscle
dysmorphia on the basis of anyone who
wants to go to the gym is a little bit
critical of their appearance and wants
to look better we'd all have the
disorder we'd all be in therapy right
now but it's not the case that the
disorder is characterized to simplify
things by two things the first is
preoccupation now preoccupation in
about Clinical Psychology a very
specific time it's not just this is the
thing I'm super into a hobby
it's preoccupying you think about it
every single day it's something that
even when you want to say focus on a
conversation with a friend your mind
keeps coming back to it
it might be that you're training you're
dieting it's something that you just
cannot stop thinking about focusing on
planning around to the point where you
start to stress if you aren't going to
be able to eat the food that you need as
part of your diet plan if you won't have
control over the food if you think
there's a chance that your training
might be a bit compromised the next day
if you go and do this social plan you
start to make compromises like this and
one of the good red flags that we look
out for is well in the context of an
interview we'd ask this but your
listeners could do it as a
self-reflection is to think about how
you would feel if you couldn't train for
one week
now
if you don't have muscle dysmorphia
you might just find that irritating or
disappointing now you've got goals
people want to make their goals folks
with my sort of small if you're good at
doing it so totally fine but when you
have a problem that one week that's
anxiety a lot of it might be guilt guys
might say you know I would feel like
[__] if I don't have it if I miss my
training then like the whole day is
pretty much wasted forget about it
um there's shame there's guilt there's a
lot of very mean body commentary they
might feel like their muscles are
shrinking like they're going backwards
and then suddenly you know the the mean
voice in their head is all they can
think about until it goes away when they
step back into the gym and they're back
on Lock and things feel okay again so
that sounds like you then you're
potentially flirting with muscle
dysmorphia territory that was the first
one what's the second one
oh yeah thank you for thank you for
keeping me in check so the second one is
impairment right so generally speaking
in clinpsych if you don't have
impairment if you are suffering and your
relationships aren't suffering your work
your study if your day-to-day
functioning is fine then you don't have
a problem like I don't care if you're in
the gym uh six days a week uh three
hours a day if you've got a really
tightly controlled diet if the fridge is
full of Tupperware containers and that's
all that's there and you bring like
little little packets of fat-free salad
dressing out to hang with your friends
if you're loving your life
and you're you're you've got
relationships you're happy with friends
with family if if you can take your
shirt off during sex or at the beach
then you don't have muscle dysmorphia
you just you're just super into the gym
a lot more into the gym than I am but
like you're just super into the gym man
it's fine
but if you are the sort of person for
whom life outside of the gym is
controlled by the gym and controlled by
training and controlled by calorie
restriction and diet and macros that's
it
yeah then it then it's not and what's
what's really tricky in eating disorders
and muscle dysmorphia is this thing in
Clinical Psychology called
egocentinicity where it feels like it's
working for you the disorder feels like
it's a a good thing
if you have depression no one wakes up
with depression goes ah this is so great
I love feeling miserable every day and
doing nothing but when you're in the
throes of anorexia you could be in the
hospital with a feeding tube down your
nose but because you're so wrapped up in
the need to be thin and to not eat
you can convince yourself and try
convince the others around you but
actually everything's fine like it's
going it's going great similar thing can
happen in muscle dysmorphia guys lives
can be slowly falling apart they can
have Partners saying look this this is
it's it's really intense now like you're
getting really intense maybe they're
starting to lose friendships but hey if
it's better than being fat or it's
better than like drinking and doing
drugs on the weekend like everyone else
you can rationalize it as something good
for you and it's only when you look back
that you go ah damn I was in deep I did
not see it far as bad as it was this is
one of the most interesting elements I
think of your work which is muscle
dysmorphia is one of the very few mental
disorders which has positive
reinforcement and not only positive
reinforcement individually but positive
reinforcement socially as well
there are very very few things if you if
your schizophrenia is getting worse and
you're strolling down the street as with
your friends talking to yourself or
pointing out all of the animals that
aren't there yeah there's very few pets
on them precisely whereas if you rock up
after having spent the last three months
monk molding it in your house You've
Lost Your Girlfriend your testosterone
through the floor you hate yourself you
can't bear to look in the mirror but
you've managed to gain you know five
pounds of muscle and you've lost a
couple of percent of body fat your
friends will go yo dude you're looking
in fact yeah you've been training you
look jacked you look good yeah
look it's deeply frustrating for for us
too because you know you could have a
young woman with anorexia who we're
trying to say
don't do this don't get this thin
I know that you've got beliefs about
what people are attracted to or desire
what gets you respect as a young woman
but it's not be all and end-all and when
she says to us but people treat me
better as I get smaller she's not wrong
right that's a difficult spot to be in
it's a difficult thing to resolve guys
are muscle dysmorphia are just the same
you know they've put in all this work to
get to a certain size and in some
respects their life may have improved
right if for them what is important and
it often is is you know I'm more
desirable I get more respect Uh I that
it it it isn't sufficient to offset all
of the energy that's going in and the
crumbling that's happening around just
makes it really hard to do such a
nuanced point to try and get across that
the net benefit
from this is in the negative overall
that when you cross into the I can't
bear to go away on holiday dude I
remember I remember as a young
20-something guy I would be I would go
on holiday to places that were within a
close radius of the gyms because I knew
that I had to train yeah and if I was
going away to Ibiza with with the boys
we'd go away to Ibiza maybe twice a year
or something each summer and I'd do a
cut I'd do a hard cut for you know eight
or ten weeks to get that one photo or to
to look good at the beach club uh when I
traveled around Thailand when I was
27 28 this was a little bit more well
balanced I was coming out the sort of
the back of uh the aesthetic side but I
basically did my entire trip around
Thailand moving from Muay Thai gym to
Mai Thai gym that that was the
foundation of my day that felt a little
bit more holistic because it was the
people I was going to hang with and I
know had similar similar goals but I can
see this you know move from more
pathological to less pathological uh I
can see that Arc in my own life I can
observe it happening to myself so yeah
thinking about the fact that and it's
such an easy Trope on the internet right
to say well look at all of these fat
[__] 60 of America's overweight 40 of
America's obese what do you want me to
do you just want me want me to be one of
those low testosterone [__] just like
the rest of the world you're like no
yeah no no absolutely not it's not
denying the fact that you can take tons
and tons of value both yourself and in
terms of how you're uh respected your
prestige your ability to show dominance
and feel confident and comfortable in
the world yeah and that the world is
going to reinforce it and they're going
to make you feel better about yourself
yeah but there's a limit bro
uh
I agree you know I call it boring
solutions to exciting problems because
the problem is exciting right and in
your head that the solution you know to
find balance and everything in
moderation is it's it's not very
tick-tockable you know what I mean and
it's hard to grasp especially when
you're young and
stories like the one you're talking
about super super common I think lots of
guys lots of girls have experiences like
that and didn't necessarily mean that
they had muscle dysmorphia or an eating
disorder in the same way that you can be
an 18 or 19 year old and be getting uh
blind drunk at some parties it doesn't
mean you're an alcoholic but you
certainly put yourself in a situation
where it was you know
a chance that a higher chance than it is
perhaps now when you know like myself
you have a two pale ales on a Friday and
then you're home so so yeah yeah I I do
feel for young people trying to navigate
this and I don't think that things like
social media are very uh assistive to
young people looking for frames of
reference
um it's pretty tough if you want a
realistic depiction of what other
people's bodies look like Instagram is
not the place to go right I was looking
to I I
um went back through some photos of me
from
2018 I think 2017 2018 and I remember at
the time this was after a big injury
that I'd had and I dropped tons of
condition and I'd got smaller and
lighter and it was after this year that
I'd been in really great condition I
remember thinking at the time card I
look so [__] compared with how I was now
and then I looked dude I looked at these
photos and I [__] you not I'm like that
is that condition is outrageous like
absolutely outrageous striations across
my chest vascularity running out from my
Delta cross under my chest
and looking back now I think [__] I wish
I could be in that condition Jesus I'm
like a a fat slow slovenly mess in
comparison with that now and I'm sure
that in 20 years time I'm going to look
back at the condition I'm in now and
think what the [__] are you doing so
there is a there's a degree of
I guess uh disbelief that we have on
varying scales about how we look and
it's persistent yeah
and and folks are very self-critical in
this regard the like you see your body
in the mirror every single day you are
so much more familiar with it than
anyone else even a long time partner
right and your ability to to criticize
different parts of you and to see
imperfections that other people don't
see and then to disbelieve those other
people and they tell you that they don't
see it you don't have anything to worry
about is is pretty impressive but we we
do it we do it all the time and it's not
surprising I think that in studies of
what men and women find ideally
attractive in the opposite sex with
respect to muscularity and body fat
men think that women want bodies that
are far more muscular than what they
actually want and women think men want
bodies that are far skinnier and when
they're asked to select you know
proportions of men who they think have a
type that is oh they want skinny women
with big boobs and then for men tall men
with broad shoulders it's that that
wildly Divergent on that tooth all of
the Nuance that comes in your 20s and
30s when you finally encounter people
who can say oh you know actually I
actually kind of like men who are a bit
more way fish and effemine I don't like
the big jacked Bros 20 year olds I kind
of loathe to believe that
and then you realize oh it actually is
the case there's a lot more diversity in
terms of what people are attracted to to
sure there's a general Trend but and you
cannot base World Views on General
Trends it's too black and white correct
yeah there is an average I think you
know on average taller guys will be more
successful in the dating Market on
average guys that have a broader
shoulder to waist ratio will be more
successful on average guys with a lower
voice on average guys with a full head
of hair but Jason Statham [__] like
he's saying is it Rosie Rosie Huntington
whatever her face is that like [__]
hyper model from the UK that was in
Transformers you know the my point being
that there are particular markets for
pretty much every single niche and
um you know I I don't think I'm not the
guy that's going to advise anybody not
to go to the gym I think that for every
guy the you know it's protective I
learned this from Ed Hagan the other
week that it's protective against
depression that depression when you
control for pretty much everything else
depression seems to be just uh it seems
to be very highly correlated with
physical uh like fragility the less
physically fragile you are the more
robust you are defended mentally against
depression through how you show up
physically so I'm like yo go and train
your hand grip or whatever it is that it
goes on but yeah it's it's such a it
must be fascinating to try and pass all
of this apart because you've got a world
which will reward people for being in
good condition
that taken to the extreme will get more
reward but will begin to cause costs to
the individual it's like a reverse
tragedy of the commons it's like a
tragedy of the individual
um so I know that
I think you've I've heard you say that
20s the typical avatar for this would be
a guy in his 20s or his 30s uh that is
going to the gym and maybe using
steroids and doing the blah blah why
does it start to drop off in 40s
well some folks will go and get
treatment
but
I think another significant contributor
and you see this for a number of
psychological conditions including
things like social anxiety uh it's
called spontaneous remission and
it's where the disorder kind of resolves
on its own and the process of that
happening is not dissimilar to how you
felt about training and dieting when you
were say 20 compared to now it's not
that you're a fundamentally different
person you've just relaxed in certain
areas you perhaps Diversified your
priorities you probably have a more
stable sense of self and self-esteem
that's like internal to you not external
contingent on others so
you would be less likely to have muscle
dysmorphia you would be less likely to
be socially anxious it might push you
below the threshold for having the
disorder anymore now you can just be the
guy in the gym who enjoys being there
and gets all the physical benefits of
exercise which as you mentioned are are
numerous and very real and you want as
many people in there enjoying those
benefits for what they are as possible
are people less satisfied with their
bodies now than ever before
yes
how do you track that
there are good general population
estimates of body dissatisfaction for
men in women men and women in several
countries
and to take Australia for example it's
unfortunately the case that you know far
from all of this uh
awareness and advocacy diminishing body
dissatisfaction among women we've just
watched the rate of body dissatisfaction
for men climb up at a faster rate than
women such that at some point in the
future we could conceivably achieve
parity so we're not making progress
there and it's not unsurprising because
I have not felt for one since that one
second sorry that the importance Society
puts on physical appearance and the a
broad Arbiter that it gets to be of
social success and Prestige has
diminished that that hasn't gone
anywhere so it's no wonder that uh when
people feel anxieties about you know
being in this this social Arena that uh
they succumb to it there's companies
everywhere who will cater to your
anxieties influences who will have those
anxieties whether intentionally or not
inflamed that stuff's all still there
how have representations of men changed
over the last few decades
they have become more muscular and
that's not just anecdote that's from
research we can show that
representations of male bodies in a
variety of media have become more
disproportionate relative to the average
male you can look at things like action
figurines where
say Luke Skywalker Han Solo from the
original Star Wars the action figurines
look like normal regular guys but then
for the re-release they look jacked you
can see this for Superman Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles Batman uh when you look at
magazines when you look at TV you see a
similar pattern as well so in terms of
being a young guy growing up and you're
thinking oh how am I supposed to look am
I attractive am I hot and you look for a
frame of reference let's say you see a
hundred male bodies in your media diet
per week the 100 that you see today in
you do come out on the negative end of
those comparisons much more than you did
20 30 years ago you're you're not
measuring up as far as you're concerned
in your own hit a lot more than you used
to I heard you talk as well about the uh
switch from thin spell to fitspo for
girls yeah can you explain that
yeah and that that sucks so
in the in the late 90s early 2000s Prime
Mana for inspiration huge thing on
Tumblr and elsewhere where the goal was
to be as thin and skinny as possible and
you'd see lots of motivating images and
memes being like you know nothing tastes
as good as skinny feels Etc do you
remember thigh gaps do you remember in
thigh gaps returned
oh I remember and that they're still
there they come up on Tick Tock uh
reasonably regular like a cycle of body
Trends and inspiration emerged as this
quasi
healthy balance right where it's like
don't just be a wife don't be dead and
skinny get healthy and build some muscle
but the bodies that you see in images
that are valorizing right uh this fit
and healthy lifestyle you'll have a
woman who is very skinny and has a
six-pack and I'm sure you would be
familiar as many of your listeners
probably are that if you're a a woman
who wants to both be thin strong and
have a six-pack it's going to be even
harder work than if you're a guy it's
it's it's even more impossible to get
that body type and the idea that we've
you know made this
gigantic Improvement in representation
for women's bodies that we've just given
them another thing to chase very
interesting man I I see you know I've
got a number of friends uh Lucy Davies
is one of them she's marrying my good
friend Ben and she had eating disorder
and she regularly posts photos of
herself
um you know like
from when she was at the depths of of
anorexia and she was super super thin
and now she's you know like she runs and
does all this stuff and she eats peanut
butter sandwiches and has an almond
class on but doesn't really care so much
um but there is a there is an element
here where I think a lot of the girls
Downstream from that or some of the
girls Downstream from that
now have two battles they're waging a
war on two fronts that it's not just
that they're trying to be thin it's like
right because I need to be thin but I
also need to be able to deadlift 100
kilos and you know that's that's that's
also tough so yeah I super tough well I
guess because you're coming at this from
a clinical Psychiatry perspective I
don't think that anybody would argue
that a woman who is you know at probably
a healthy BMI
who is holding
um more muscle uh whose bone density is
improved who's got a better VO2 max he's
got a better resting heart rate heart
rate variability all of this stuff
physiologically they are probably
objectively significantly better than
the size zero girl that had dieted
themselves into the floor
but from a clinical Psychiatry
perspective
I imagine that there isn't actually all
that much difference they're still
ruminating about their body image still
obsessing trying to dial absolutely
everything in still probably got
terrible better uh ruminative thoughts
about the way that they look and stuff
like that uh and I guess this is a
difficult line to pass as well again
objectively the world is not only going
to say yeah you look good and wow that's
healthy and you know it's so much better
than when you were really really thin
but where's the drive coming from
mentally how much of that has been fixed
yeah exactly the underlying psychology
is is still there and that's part of the
reason why we often see in guise of
muscle dysmorphia
they've had a history of anorexia or
guys with uh
rexia fed a history of muscle dysmorphia
because the underlying psychology is the
same maybe the disorder got really rough
and so they they engaged with some
medical professionals or talk to people
in their life who said okay maybe just
try and pull back on this and instead
they've just they've shunted it in the
other direction because there's still
that same person
uh and they they get caught up in it
again we call it is it the tyranny of
progress
The Tyranny the tyranny of progress
because
oh the progress comes up and The
Narrative of people with muscle
dysmorphia constantly they have to be
progressing they have to be getting
better because they didn't used to be
how they are now they were deficient in
some or many ways and now they've
finally got to this point where they can
be okay with themselves but they need to
get more and you have to be on luck with
your diet you're training to progress
but it's a tyranny because it's never
enough you know a good sign that you
don't have muscle dysmorphia is if you
set yourself a goal and you get there
and then you're just happy with yourself
great like you you achieved a goal
that's that's awesome that won't happen
in muscle dysmorphia or it'll be
fleeting you'll feel good for the day
and the next day it's like ah yeah but
I've still got that I've still got quite
a bit of fat around the midsection don't
I and then off you are again on another
another little God what do you think
about lifestyle dysmorphia or personal
development dysmorphia or business
success dysmorphia are in the same
regard the tyranny of those different
things
yeah I've got you so look I think any
time you put all of your eggs in my
basket and have your self-esteem and
sense of self-worth and what makes you
feel like you're in control of your life
coming from One Source you just make
yourself super vulnerable that's a
fragile psychology right
and it's no wonder that we have so many
terms like Workaholics for example uh
none of some of these uh have lent
themselves more to Clinical Psychology
and psychiatry in a way of diagnosis
then Oh you mean that you haven't you
haven't managed to come up with some
sort of diagnosis DSM statistical manual
for monk mode grind set Sigma males
oh believe me I'm trying is out there
trying to diagnose as many as I can and
and bring that money in
um but no but no but I take a broader
point right because you are correct that
the the way Clinical Psychology and
diagnosis are set up we more readily
recognize the pathology that comes from
the singular pursuit of some things we
have procupation and less with others
because Workaholics can ruin their lives
but we we're not going to see that as a
diagnosis anytime soon I suspect so
interesting man it's like this
uh cyclical dissatisfaction or this
ambient dissatisfaction that happens I
have a goal I work to the goal I achieve
the goal I'm dissatisfied I set another
goal I presume that this goal was the
way it was because I didn't it wasn't
big enough it wasn't long enough it
wasn't
whatever enough yeah and um
you know I I'm really trying to square
this circle as somebody who takes an
awful lot of value in progress in life
in becoming better and growing his
impact in
um improving day by day
um
and I wonder how much of I've said this
for to myself for a very long time
how much of your personal development is
papering over the cracks of
fundamentally not being happy with the
person that you are and feeling that
you're not worthy of love and acceptance
and praise unless you are making
progress and the reason that progress is
able to paper over those cracks is
because as long as you're continuing to
make progress it doesn't matter if
you're dissatisfied with yourself right
now because the version that you are
tomorrow might be the one that you can
finally be satisfied with
yeah and you'll find out how much of a
problem it is once there is a setback or
something that stops you from making
progress because if it's a if it is an
issue that's substantial lurking in the
background you won't find that enjoyable
at all and it's a matter of balance you
know that boring solution to exciting
problems again where you I think
achieving and being driven is important
for people to feel good about themselves
and having a core
inalterable sense of your worth as a
person is core as well you need both and
both of that just makes for a healthy
individual that's a strong psychology
that is resilient against the world and
it can grow and evolve as a person
strives and succeeds that's a really
good point and I think that again it's a
subtle one but an important one to think
that
for all of the people who are part of
the sigma mail grind set mode thing
which I fall into so I had [__] David
Goggins on the podcast a couple of
months ago right like he's the ultimate
[__] that man is grinding he's the
ultimate discipline bro yeah correct we
always be grinding
um but
there is an element I think and I would
say this to David if if you require this
complex framework of uh daily activities
in order to buttress your sense of self
and I don't know whether this is true I
don't know whether if he did take time
off how bad he would feel about himself
but if that is the case
how can you say that that's a robust
State of Mind the the whole goal here
that the internet and a lot the spaces
that I inhabit valorize is this you know
kind of like
spartan-esque very sort of tough guy I
can deal with the discomfort I can deal
with the fragility okay well deal with
an injury for two weeks or deal with not
being not being able to go to the gym
you know like how what happens if you're
not allowed to train or follow your diet
for two weeks time how resilient are you
then
when there's no enemy to fight there's
no way to lift there's no battle to wage
how resilient are you then and I think
that that's a really interesting and a
very uncomfortable question because most
people would say oh but that's you know
that's just like that's a that's a
cooked mentality you don't need to worry
about that like you just you keep
grinding man like you know you just work
through the difficulty and you go okay
well
why is it genuinely and you need to ask
yourself this question with a very sort
of gentle and open heart
is it because you want to be better is
it because you have a fear of not being
enough
and how much is your drive how much is
your drive coming from both of these one
of the other things that you did you
worked with grinder not personally well
like professionally you worked with
Grindr what about the gays tell me about
the gays Scott what do we know about the
gays
I've got you well uh first and foremost
the gays are doing just fine they do
experience higher rates of eating
disorders and muscle dysmorphia
and significant part because you've got
more appearance pressures in community
cause of that if you want to feel like
you belong if you want to feel like uh
you've you know got the right
credentials to be in gay spaces whether
it's night clubs or uh the you know
famous Mardi Gras parade here in Sydney
feel like the way you look is a pretty
significant part of that so guys are
more susceptible to muscle the smaller
Eating Disorders because of that okay
game it men sometimes objectify the
thing that they sexually desire is that
news
uh I believe I believe so I believe that
I don't know I don't know if we'll go
International but uh it's definitely
newsworthy
well
there's been um for quite a while I know
I have a number of gay friends and
it seems to me that gay men are a lot
more open around their preferences for
what they want especially physically
from a partner
um I know that sometimes they list
things on their dating profiles about
what they do and do not accept and stuff
like that I imagine that plays into this
yeah it does and it's you can think of
the like listing of a a laundry list of
physical traits that gay men aren't as
sexual partners or Partners in
journaling other gay men has one
manifestation of that
appearance-centric culture it's
something we would point to to say that
you know it's it's physical appearance
is more prized in these spaces and yeah
I think that it makes it very very tough
and certainly when we interview gay men
about this they will very quickly tell
us of uh a universally implicit but
often made explicit hierarchy of
physical traits in the gay male
Community where some are very prized
like being tall being muscular being
white whereas others push you further
down that hierarchy and a lot of gay men
feel comfortable just saying you know no
no fats no Femmes
um that kind of energy
just gay people are so they don't give a
[__] man like they don't like there's a
large a large cohort of them who simply
don't and I suppose as well this kind of
plays out of the male
um
trend of of banter and of sort of
digging and of being able to take a jab
that a guy on Tinder or hinge but uh no
fats no like masks or something
um is is
probably going to come up against some
distaste but in an environment where
it's other guys and you know no matter
how gay and defeminate you have grown up
in your childhood you've been subject to
more male banter and male banter means
that you can take the [__] a little bit
and if the [__] in includes no fats no
Femmes
well you know like you were like you've
been prepping for this your entire life
Buckle like this yeah this is part of
your culture
and like uh the reason the reason we
advertise studies on Grinders when we
advertise on grinder we our
advertisements go out Nationwide because
we don't just want to talk to people in
our own Circle we want to know people
are actually thinking and okay we talked
to so many gay men and the one thing
that always happens they all know that
it's a problem no one is thrilled about
this very appearance rampant
objectification
like it it doesn't mean they don't
participate in it whether with some
regret or not that they can all point to
it and they can all at the very least
say I don't think it's very helpful like
it can be a pretty uh mean and
dispiriting place to be as a gay man in
a gay male Community because of those
kinds of attitudes and expectations but
as for Solutions those are harder to
come by the problem is that we're
fighting with human desire here right
like we don't have a massive amount of
control if any at all over the things
that we desire we can have control over
the actions that we take around the
things that we do or don't desire
many people that are listening will have
done things physically with people that
they didn't desire that much or maybe
didn't really desire at all and vice
versa two uh
so I think that a challenge that we have
here is
you know we can roll this back into the
hetero conversation by saying well I can
say that because I've got this handlebar
mustache at the moment I'm allowed to
bridge the bridge the gap
um
what's interesting there is look at the
uh increase in objectification was is
object am I using the right word though
would it be objectification or like
focus on physical appearances
yeah so I don't think it's necessarily
objectification but focus on physical
okay um that gay men uh find when
they're on these sorts of apps now the
reason that straight men don't feel
quite the same amount is that the other
sex that they're being judged by has a
different list of criteria this is to
say not to say that women don't have a
high a big list of criteria it's just
other things right it's you
yeah money status etc etc a bunch of
other traits that you can have
um but I do think that you know and it's
certainly giving me a little bit of
pause to think okay if gay men are
reporting this very overly emphasized
um
focus on physical appearance
what's it like for women because women
are in the market of men
right
yeah we are the supply to the demand
problem
yeah I mean women having seen for a long
time that it's extremely tough to be
subject to male desire that so
overwhelmingly privileges
and positions physical appearances the
the central Arbiter like it's a it's a
it's a very tough spot to be and I think
hard to reconcile right like you can put
all this effort it seems to you into
diversifying the number of things that
ought to make you you think a attractive
potential partner to someone but and
then to learn a physical appearance
constitutes such a significant part of
that I think I think is pretty
disempowering and I always try to get
young men who are criticizing what they
believe to be the unfair physical
appearance preferences of women uh to
take stock of the very clear robust
research finding that actually women are
much more chill on your physical
appearance than you are on them on
average uh yeah which I'm sure you're
familiar yeah I am and and it again the
the trend on the internet at the moment
especially in a lot of the manosphere
spaces is that um women's hypergamous
nature and the fact that any guy can fly
them out to Dubai at the drop of a hat
and they're going to be a Shake's wife
and no other guy can compete with them
means that yeah the high probability
scenario yeah I mean means that uh
women's
um selection criteria is out of the
window and that all of these normal men
are just been able to get a look in I'd
don't deny that there's a tall girl
problem of hypergamy given that women
are over achieving in education and
employment comparative with men I think
that there has been a massive Retreat of
men from The Mating Market that isn't
assisting them and I also think that men
are being accused of not only being the
tyrants of everybody else's downfall but
of their own as well there are very few
groups where when they have a problem
we say pull yourself up by your
bootstraps instead we spend billions of
taxpayer-funded money to try and create
initiatives and Charities and startups
to you know Title IX was introduced in
an effort to do that and I I you know
[__] I have hopped on for as long as is
possible trying to like
sing the song of men being forgotten
right to the point where I've been
accused by Guardian readers of being a
bigot but because I don't believe that
women have it just super easy and that
no man is sexually
um or in terms of appearance is over
focusing on that to the detriment of
women's mental health a lot of the time
that also causes me to be like a blue
pill cook so I I again
appropriately as it straddles my mouth
it straddles both sides of the of the
conversation
um
I
I really really think that this
discussion trying to work out or trying
to teach people about what
each side finds attractive the
differences that you can have and and
how that's a challenge is really really
[__] important
one of the common
tropes that we're seeing on the internet
at the moment which you must have become
familiar with is height anxiety amongst
men
yeah we've we've we've put a fair bit of
effort into studying this for a while
tell me tell me all about it guys are
getting [__] FEMA extension surgery
they're wearing shoes that increase
their height there's stats coming out of
Okay Cupid and Tinder about if you're
below five nine don't even bother
getting on there what's what's the
current state of mental health and men's
height like
it
look it it's it's it's definitely a
prominent anxiety it is
less severe in all respects no matter
how you approach it then you might think
so the number of men who are anxious
about their height is less than you
think the number of women who care about
height is less than you think
um the number of men going out and doing
something as drastic as a leg
lengthening surgery is less than you
think
it's just generally less of a like
what's the issue when he's like a
population exploding issue then it might
otherwise seem but it's definitely the
case that for a bunch of men it
it really sucks and it's it's
understandable why and there are
certainly there's certainly a preference
among women for tall women out there uh
but that's that's about where it ends
because there are preferences for women
and men toward all sorts of physical
attributes and another thing worth
noting is that
it's very easy for people to say that
they have a preference like people can
say oh you know this is I'm into this
and then you might see them dating
someone who's completely different
they're almost surprised by who it is
that they ended up being attracted to or
with and that that tends to happen quite
a lot too like you know you can you can
say you might be a young woman who wants
to date men being like I want to date a
tall guy but then you're out maybe you
meet at a five foot nine dive is really
funny you're like huh and then look
maybe maybe you don't but someone's
already taken what you tweeted saying I
like tall guys and being like look
they're all like this and now it's a
it's a big flame war on the internet how
do you pass apart stated and reveal
preferences when it comes to this
because it seems like that's the real
challenge here yeah
that's that's tricky this this starts to
move away from my expertise admittedly
because we're getting into social
science as opposed to Clinical
Psychology I think you either have to
follow people up in terms of how they've
actually dated which is tricky from a
statistical power standpoint a few other
things or you can corroborate it with
data from things like Okay Cupid Etc I
know okay Cupid's data blog and dump
often gets trotted out uh in support of
various arguments in their space
um and yeah they can
be a difference between people's stated
intentions and they're revealed but
again
it tends to be not as drastic as people
think as far as I can tell as well
that's interesting what about penis size
sensitivity is this something you've
looked at
yeah and this one like because we've
we've outright looked at how many people
are dissatisfied with their height is
men men straight men and gay men how
dissatisfied they are with their height
their muscles their body fat and their
penis we pitted all four against each
other because we wanted an actual answer
to this uh penis dissatisfaction was
right down the bottom like very few men
this that we said like this this
stereotype that you know when guys get
uh worried about how they look it's just
because they they want their dick to be
bigger I think that's like a
generation's old Trope I just don't
think as many men are worried about that
as we might think by and large what men
worry about is I wish I didn't have uh
as much body fat on me and which my
biceps were bigger like that's what's
the what was the percentages and the
order stuff for those four uh statements
can you remember
so you'll have penis size
dissatisfaction at the bottom and I've
hyped the satisfaction above that and
then you'll have muscularity and body
fat sitting quite similarly and it
changes according to age so for young
men it will be muscle dissatisfaction
that's worse then body fat
dissatisfaction I think because you know
a lot of young men they've they've
possibly been skinnier growing up anyway
but then as people get older the the
battle quote unquote turns to body fat
less muscularity so body fat starts to
become the thing they're most worried
about and body fat dissatisfaction
muscularity dissatisfaction for for
young men almost normative so in the
field we call it normative in the sense
that it's more normal to find someone
who says yeah I'm not happy with the
amount of body fat or muscularity on me
than to say that I'm happy but when it
comes to like penis size dissatisfaction
we're talking uh under one in ten so
nine and ten men will say yeah
I'm fine with the way my penis looks uh
and height probably around six seven and
ten happy with that height
dissatisfaction drops off with age as
well what's the um proportion of men who
say weight or muscularity can you
remember
oh
for gay men I think that will be up
at 60.
for straight men
for straight men I can't recall it
separable it's probably around
40 35 to 40. it's still a massive
portion we're speaking to a huge number
and again
I I don't know man I
there's not a single guy I know
I don't think who if I ask them
would you like to lose a bit of body fat
or would you like a bit more muscularity
that wouldn't say yes I know anybody
there was there's no one listening to
this there's no one listening to this
but there's also no one listening to
this that says dude if you just go do
you want an extra like you know inch in
girth is not going to go yeah why not
you know like there's room in the garage
like Global fit we'll fit it in
um yeah no one's not going to say that
that's
yeah exactly but there's there's a
distinction between like if it was
offered to would you take it and and I
am unhappy with this thing so I agree
with you I think most men if offered
something like you know would you want
an extra inch of high or an inch of hand
size it's almost like a yeah well I mean
why not it's not going to hurt but
that's I think that's the mentality
whereas a lot of men offered say an inch
more on their bicep or an inch off their
waist they're like yeah because like I
think my arms are skinny or I I actually
do wish uh that I was fixing fixing a
deficiency the status it's
dissatisfaction as opposed to like
well yeah if you're going to offer it
then yes Scott Griffiths ladies and
gentlemen Scott I think this stuff is
absolutely fascinating I love the work
that you're doing I can't wait to see
what you do next what should people go
if they want to keep up to date with the
work and the the Publications and all
the rest of it we got somewhere on the
internet that you can direct them
yeah you can follow me on Twitter uh at
scottline Griffis
um yeah and thanks for having me a
really thoughtful questions I've
appreciated them what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
face